WILL: DESPITE ENACTING SOME OF
THE TOUGHEST LOCKDOWN RULES IN
THE COUNTRY GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM IS FACING A SURGE IN NEW
COVID CASES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
OUR NEXT GUEST CALLING STRICT
LOCKDOWNS A "FAILURE OF
IMAGINATION" ON BEHALF OF
LAWMAKERS.
HERE TO EXPLAIN IS DR. JAY BATAC
HERIA, PROFESSOR OF
MEDICINE AT STANFORD, UNIVERSITY
THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH US
IT DOES SEEM LIKE LOCKDOWN,
LOCKDOWN, LOCKDOWN IT’S THE CURE
-ALL AND THE ALMOST
REFLEXIVE RESPONSE FROM POLICY
MAKERS.
TELL ME WHY THAT’S A FAIL YOU’RE
OF IMAGINATION?
>> I MEAN, THE KEY THING IS IT
DOESN’T RESPECT THE FACTS ABOUT
THIS EPIDEMIC AND THE VIRUS.
THE VIRUS SPREADS IN HOUSEHOLDS.
IT SPREADS BASICALLY IN WAYS
THAT WE KIND OF KNOW WHERE THE
LOCKDOWN SORT OF SUPPRESSES
SOCIETY IN PLACES WHERE THE
VIRUS DOESN’T NECESSARILY
SPREAD A LOT.
IT ALSO, I MEAN, IT REDUCES OUR
ABILITY TO REACT TO THE VIRUS.
SO FOR INSTANCE WE CLOSED OUR
SCHOOLS.
WELL THAT MEANS A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO WORK IN FRONTLINE SETTINGS,
THEY HAVE KIDS, AND THEY CAN’T
GO TO WORK BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
TAKE CARE OF THEIR KIDS.
THE LOCKDOWN ITSELF, ALL IT EVER
, EVEN THEORETICALLY ALL IT
DOES IS IT DELAYS WHEN THE
INFECTIONS OCCUR.
IN A SENSE, WHAT’S HAPPENED IN
CALIFORNIA, WE HAVE BUNCHED THEM
UP ALL RIGHT NOW, AND OUR
HOSPITALS ARE STARTING TO GET
STRESSED AS A RESULT.
I MEAN, OUR HOSPITALS ARE EMPTY
FOR LARGE PARTS OF THE SPRING
AND THE SUMMER, WEIRDLY.
WILL: RIGHT, THE IDEA BEHIND
LOCKDOWNS WASN’T TO KILL THE
VIRUS, IT WAS TO BEND THE
CURVE.
THAT’S WHAT WE WERE TOLD IN
EARLY SPRING SO WHAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN A BETTER POLICY
RESPONSE, DOCTOR?
>> WELL, WE KNOW THAT OLDER
PEOPLE, PEOPLE OVER 70, HAVE A
95% SURVIVAL RATE FROM THE VIRUS
5% MORTALITY IS PRETTY HIGH,
WHEREAS UNDER 70, THE SURVIVAL
RATE IS 99.95%, SO THOSE  .05%
MORTALITY.
OLDER PEOPLE ARE THE ONES WHO
ARE AT RISK.
WE SHOULD HAVE DONE EVERYTHING
WE COULD POSSIBLY DO TO PROTECT
OLDER POPULATION.
LET ME GIVE YOU ONE FAILURE
WHERE I THINK IT JUST IS SO
OBVIOUS ONCE YOU SAY IT.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE SAY 64,
65, THEY HAVE DIABETES, THEY ARE
ACTUALLY AT MY RISK OF MORTALITY
AND MAYBE A CLERK IN A GROCERY
STORE OR  A JANITOR SO WE CALL
THEM ESSENTIAL AND EXPOSE THEM
TO THE VIRUS.
WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN PROTECTING
THEM.
OUR POLICY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DESIGNED TO GIVE THEM LEAVE.
WILL: MORE TAILORED, LESS BLUNT
THAT SEEMS PRETTY OBVIOUS.
I HAVE TO GET TO TWO BIG
IMPORTANT STORIES REALLY QUICKLY
YOU BROUGHT UP ELDERLY PEOPLE IN
OUR SOCIETY WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE.
THERE IS THIS EMERGING DEBATE
AMONG HEALTH EXPERTS WHO SHOULD
BE PRIORITIZED WHEN IT COMES TO
THE VACCINE.
SHOULD IT BE OLDER AMERICANS OR
SHOULD IT BE USED AS A CHANCE
FOR RACIAL EQUITY?
SHOULD WE PRIORITIZE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS WHO HAVE MORE MINORITY
POPULATIONS?
MORE REPRESENTED BY MINORITY
SHOULD WE BE TAKING RACE INTO
ACCOUNT, DOCTOR?
>> I THINK THAT THE KEY THING
IS IF WE WANT TO MINIMIZE
MORTALITY FROM THIS VIRUS WHAT
WE NEED TO DO IS PRIORITIZE
OLDER PEOPLE AND ESPECIALLY
PEOPLE WITH CHRONIC CONDITIONS.
MINORITY POPULATIONS WITH
CHRONIC CONDITIONS SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED, ABSOLUTELY,
ESPECIALLY OLDER PEOPLE, I MEAN,
I THINK THAT’S THE KEY QUESTION.
WHAT DO YOU WANT, IF YOU WANT TO
REDUCE DEATH FROM THIS VIRUS,
PRIORITIZE OLDER POPULATIONS.
WILL: SEEMS OBVIOUS.
REALLY QUICKLY BECAUSE YOU’RE
FROM STANFORD I HAVE TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THE STORY CONTROVERSY
ABOUT STANFORD PRIORITIZING
PROFESSORS AT THE HIGHER-LEVEL
NOT THE FRONTLINE WORKERS.
WHAT’S YOUR RESPONSE TO WHAT
HAPPENED IN STANFORD IN THE
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION THERE?
>> YEAH, I THINK THEY MADE A
MISTAKE, WITH PEOPLE LIKE ME, I
GUESS, I HAVEN’T HAD THE VACCINE
AS YET, BUT THEY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN PRIORITIZING PEOPLE WHO
REALLY WERE HE FRONTLINE
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO TAKE CARE
OF OLDER PEOPLE.
WILL: REALLY GOOD INFORMATION, A
LOT IN A LITTLE AMOUNT OF TIME,